all right the house Intel Committee
Chairman Adam the cowardly shifty ship
he has been caught in yet another insane
lie now it's no secret the Cowardly ship
is dishonest deceptive he is a proven
liar nothing but a political hack and
operative
he's been proven to lie over and over
and over again we have offered him time
on this program a full hour I'll give
him a full week and five days on my
radio show that's 20 hours of
broadcasting but shifts most recent lie
uncovered in a brand new report leave it
or not although they tried to couch it a
lot still couldn't hide the fact the New
York Times may be one of his worst yet
The Times now reporting that the shifty
cowardly shift he got an early account
of the so-called whistleblowers
accusations in other words
representative Adam B shift California
learned about the so-called
whistleblower is not a whistleblower and
that whistleblower so-called concerns
before he or she filed a complaint in
fact shifts office spoke directly to the
future non whistleblower whistleblower
and even recommended that the future he
or she hire an attorney and meet with
the inspector general to file a
complaint his fingerprints all over this
this is not a real whistleblower here
say oh I heard it from so-and-so heard
and from so-and-so heard of him
so-and-so yeah that would not be
admissible in a court of law but
apparently not in the court of corrupt
Democrats who spread lies and conspiracy
theories of one hoax after another they
barely miss a beat hoax to hoax to hoax
and the sleaze bag that cowardly Schiff
himself was behind this quote
nonpartisan totally jitan legitimate
whistleblower complaint from the very
beginning this can't possibly be the
same cowardly Shipp who was from
California who actually went on
conspiracy television area51
roswell rachel's network ms D&C on
September the 17th and claimed quote we
have not spoken directly to the
whistleblower Ally take a look we have
not spoken directly with the
whistleblower we would like to but
whistleblower has concerns that he has
not been advised as the law requires by
the inspector general or the Director of
National Intelligence just as to how he
has to communicate with Congress lying
through his teeth
caught yet again and the Cowardly shift
the shifty shift well was practically
holding the whistle on the non
whistleblower keep in mind that guy the
same con artist who's now leading the
Democrats idiotic impeachment inquiry
which is totally based on the
whistleblower complaint that the shifty
shift had a hand in creating clearly and
offering advice to this is why Americans
hate the swamp known as Washington DC
the leaking the lying the scheming the
undermining the character assassination
all of it from Schiff a disgusting abuse
of power by the way he now needs to be
investigated he must be held accountable
we are calling tonight for an
independent ethics investigation into
the office of the Cowardly Adam Schiff
he must immediately now recuse himself
from any impeachment inquiry and it is
time that this liar go under oath about
his involvement in this phony
whistleblower report every American who
voted you got to understand what this is
about
you voted for Donald Trump you're a
smelly Walmart shopper like me I think
it's smart to shop at Walmart I like
Walmart you save money and you're an
irredeemable deplorable and and you're a
bitter American that clings to their God
Bible religion Second Amendment rights
you need to understand tonight that
corrupt congressman is willing to do
almost anything to remove a duly elected
president the president you voted for
his deranged lying his conspiracy
theories spreading as hoaxes are now
catching up to him he is not fit to
serve in Congress at all let alone the
chairman of this committee and sadly
what we are seeing here is nothing new
it's the same shift different day play
on words as congressman Jordan pointed
out this fits his pattern shift seems to
have a hand in virtually every
conspiratorial anti Trump's me
brought before Congress for example
summer of 2018 there was the shifty
shift the Cowardly shift a secret
meeting with fusion GPS founder Glenn
Simpson you know the guy that Robert
Muller had never heard of at the same
time Simpson whose firm was behind
Hillary's dirty dossier was of course an
important witness in his committees
investigation into alleged Russia
collusion that's been debunked now four
times and shifts team remember they
prepped Michael Cohen for ten hours just
before his testimony before his
committee on Capitol Hill Wow and now it
appears the cowardly shifty shift played
a vital role in coordinating the second
hand whistleblower complaint whether it
involves Russia Ukraine or I don't know
maybe it'll be the Bahamas impeachment
inquiry next seems that the Cowardly
ship has been plotting the president's
destruction undermining your vote lying
in the process from the second the
president was elected by you we the
American people the only problem with
his strategy was always built on a pack
of lies
remember this is the guy who actually
fabricated a transcript remember he's
the guy you didn't know he was being
well pranked and he thought he was
talking to a real Russian about dirt on
Donald Trump that he could use during an
election and by the way it was read out
loud in an official committee hearing
you know remember what's the dirt on
Donald Trump the naked pixs the tada a
and- it does matter beer No
oh my gosh anyway take a look there was
already in my view ample evidence in the
public domain on the issue of collusion
if you're willing to see it if you want
to blind yourself then you can look the
other way I can certainly say with
confidence that there is significant
evidence of collusion between the
campaign and Russia I've been very clear
over the last year year and a half that
there is ample evidence of collusion in
plain sight four separate investigations
there was no evidence of anything lie
after lie after lie after life is this
good for the country now keep in mind it
was actually the cow
if caught on tape colluding with Russia
yeah
does Vladimir see it but the cause of
Vladimir sees naked pictures of tada
remember he was trying to get the naked
pictures of the Trump he was being
pranked
in other words doing what he's accusing
Trump up but I thought Democrats were
really worried about foreign Election
interference I guess that only involves
fictional claims against President Trump
not the dirty dossier because if they
really cared about collusion or
interference where is well the cowardly
shifts hysteria over Hillary Clinton's
dirty Russian dossiers the New York
Times finally concluded likely Russian
misinformation disinformation from the
start where's the hysteria over the
DNC's collusion with Ukraine after all
according to 2017 Politico look at this
DNC operative pressed the Ukrainian
embassy to dig up dirt on Donald Trump
for Hillary during the 2016 election and
there's more look at the same political
report Ukrainian government officials
tried to help Hillary Clinton and
undermine Trump by publicly questioning
his fitness for office they also
disseminated documents implicating a top
trump aide in corruption and suggested
they were investigating the matter only
to back away after the election they
picked the wrong horse and they helped
kill Hillary Clinton's allies research
damaging information on Trump and his
advisors it's that simple
that would be foreign election
interference but according to a report
from The Wall Street Journal while we do
have two Republican senators not
Democrats who are demanding answers in
to quote the brazen efforts by the
Democratic National Committee and
Hillary Clinton and her campaign to use
the government of Ukraine for the
express purpose of finding negative
information on then candidate Trump in
order to undermine his campaign that
would be the exact thing they claim
Trump did now twice the hypocrisy is
sick it is frankly destructive and
psychotic at this point
you got the speaker and name only Pelosi
you got the the cowardly shifty shift
their pals in the media mob ignoring all
the real evidence of real collusion
they're putting their agenda
ahead of what is truthful honest and
what the American people should no real
interference real government abuse of
power
the real weaponization of America's
intelligence system oh yeah and then
FISA fraud and spying on a campaign and
a transition team and a president three
long years hyperventilating telling us
they have the truth they have the truth
one hoax after another one lie after
another one conspiracy after another
Russia Russia Russia now it's Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine let's take a look the
president himself called on the Russians
to assist his campaign by hacking
Hillary Clinton's emails was using that
office as leverage to obtain dirt have
another country manufactured dirt on his
opponent we believe that the President
of the United States is engaged in a
cover-up I think right now there's a
cover-up of the cover-up the Russians
offered help the campaign accepted help
the Russians gave help and the president
made full use of that help I don't think
we can rely on a country that is so
beholden to the good graces of Donald
Trump to to be able to level with us on
this no one is above the law especially
the President of the United States the
President believes that he has above the
law the law being the Constitution of
the United States there is already in my
view ample evidence in the public domain
on the issue of collusion if you're
willing to see it it is very powerful
evidence of that kind of potential
impeachable offense see a pattern it
would almost be funny if they weren't
trying to circumvent the will of you the
American people and literally remove a
duly elected president from office who's
doing an amazing job under the worst
circumstances and smearing the president
has been their number one goal from the
very beginning and by the way they don't
care about improving the lives of
Americans in spite of their lofty you
know cliched language from earlier today
as the president tweeted the do-nothing
Democrats should be focused on building
up our country not wasting everyone's
time and energy on BS which is what they
have been doing ever since I got
overwhelmingly elected
twenty sixteen to twenty three to three
oh six get a better candidate this time
you'll need it
by the way guys we have an election in a
year you think your ideas a superior you
think your record is better okay let's
have it out in the ring it's called the
an election let the American people
decide for once and maybe you guys can
just put your best candidate vote who
wants to spend ninety four trillion
dollars and eliminate gas oil energy the
combustion engine planes and cows run on
that 94 trillion dollar idiocy and
eliminating private insurance good luck
with that president continue to fight
back against those who want to take him
down what's this we don't call him
shifty ship for nothing he's a shifty
dishonest guy who by the way was
critical of one of the great secretary
of states graduated number one in his
class at West Point graduated top of it
one of the top of his class at Harvard
Law School the most honorable person
Mike Pompeo and this guy was negative
when Mike Pompeo he can't you know
there's an expression he couldn't carry
his blank strap I won't say it because
they'll say it was so terrible to say
but that guy couldn't carry his blank
strap do you understand that so if you
deal with bad people and you know I
watched China over the last few days and
I watched some of these other countries
build up build up build up and we've
built up more than any of them because
of me
but no help due to the Democrats or a
disaster there to do nothing Democrats
they don't do any work all they want to
do is try and win the election in 2020
so they come up with this impeachment
nonsense and everyone knows the
conversation all based on one phone call
that I had where I'm talking to the
president of Ukraine UOP R from our
ambassadors you'll hear from some of the
folks that know all about the call why
the call was set up and everything else
it's perfect the call was perfect Nancy
Pelosi and shifty shift who should
resign in disgrace by the way and Jerry
Nadler and all of them it's a disgrace
what's going on and we should be focused
on making
America great again and keeping America
great because what they did with this
nonsense think of it you have a perfect
I mean perfect conversation with a
president of another country Ukraine in
this case and they try and say oh let's
impeach him they've been trying to
impeach me from the day I got elected
I've been going through this for three
years they've been trying to impeach me
from the day I got elected and you know
what they failed and this is the easiest
one of all because this one is based on
one conversation what about Obama's
conversation with the President of
Russia where he says hey hey tell that
Vlad I'll I'll talk to him after the
elections over I'll talk to him nobody
reports that right that stuff you should
report but you people should be ashamed
of yourself we have the most dishonest
media that you can imagine and you
should be ashamed of yourselves but
here's what happened the whistleblower
was wrong the only thing that matters is
the transcript of the actual
conversation that I had with the
president of Ukraine it was perfect
we're looking at congratulations
we're looking at doing things together
and what are we looking at we're looking
at corruption and you know I believe
1999 there was a corruption act or
corruption bill passed between both hand
side between both countries where I have
a duty to report corruption and let me
tell you something
Biden's son is corrupt and Biden is
corrupt and I'd rather run against Biden
than almost any of those candidates and
I think they're all weak but I think
Biden has never been a smart guy and
he's less smart now than he ever was
thank you very much and the president's
supposed to faithfully execute the laws
of the land and that would be election
interference that those people used to
care about president also have pointed
words for her the lying corrupt media
mob and I call them a mob for a reason
because they are take a look look Biden
and his son are stone called
and you know it his son walks out with
millions of dollars the kid knows
nothing you know it and so do we go
ahead ask the question the question sir
was what did you want president Solinsky
to do about president Vice President
Biden and his son hunter yeah it was
just a follow-up of what I just asked
you sir listen you ready we have the
president of Finland ask him a question
I have one for my just wanted to follow
up on the one that I asked you which did
you hear but if you want you hear me yes
ask him a question I will but my Avenue
a long answer ask this gentleman a
question don't be rude
no sir I don't want to be rude I just
wanted you to have a chance to answer
the question that I asked is it
everything it's a whole hoax and you
know who's playing into the hoax people
like you and the fake news media that we
have in this country and I say in many
cases the corrupt media because you
corrupt much of the media in this
country is not just fake it's corrupt
corrupt lies smearing besmirching false
allegations wasting taxpayer money and
time conspiracy theories Lies hoaxes by
the way the media mob you may want to
pay attention president's going to win
on this and you're gonna help them
president just raised a whopping hundred
and twenty five million dollars in the
third quarter new poll has the
president's approval rating yep climbing
to a year-long high and by the way the
mob might not like it but under article
2 section 3 of the United States
Constitution the president has a sworn
duty to quote well take care that the
laws be faithfully executed that would
mean investigating election and
appearance like the Hillary campaign did
by paying for a dirty Russian dossier
and like what has been going on in
Ukraine that's right the weaponization
of the intelligence community oh and
using an unverified phony dossier to get
a visa application warrant four times